Dana back to the migrant crisis here in
Yuma Arizona I want audience understand
where we are where the um what amounts
to a triangle okay this is Mexico to my
right this is California you see
directly behind me where the wall is
actually finished and completed we're
about 160 Mile Stretch and then you get
to Arizona and that's where we are today
and that's where the problems have been
bad for a long time it's so bad that
border fish will say the county here in
Yuma is on the brink of collapse I'm
joined by two officials who have been at
the Spear of this from the beginning
trying to help their community and
trying to keep their country safe Yuma
County Supervisor Jonathan Lyons and the
county sheriff Leon Wilmot gentlemen
thanks for getting up early today
Sheriff you are most concerned with the
criminal element that is coming to your
county absolutely how are you dealing
with it every day is a new challenge
when it comes to securing our border and
helping our our border patrol Partners
trying to fill that Gap yeah the reason
I mention that is I just explained
geography of where we are but Yuma
County is the only County in America
that is bordered by two separate Mexican
states correct so you're dealing with
two separate Mexican cartels
it's a huge challenge because you have
Baja California which is uh the Jalisco
New Generation cartel that controls the
river Corridor in Yuma County and then I
have the Sinaloa cartel in Sonora Mexico
and they control the desert part of our
our County so anything that's done here
is coordinated by both those cartels and
it's for a reason yeah it's double
trouble too and it is Jonathan uh you're
an American you pay your taxes you get
your money's worth here no County
Supervisor you know my orcas came here
promised that he would finish the wall
hasn't done it we see a little bit of
traffic but in the meantime we've had
300 000 people that we know about come
across we're concerned about the people
who are the gotaways you know yesterday
they got somebody on the terrorist watch
list an Iranian well we want to know
about the other million people that are
coming across and where they've where
they're going and what they're doing
yeah one thing that became clear to me
after we drove down from the Super Bowl
of all places right such a uniquely
American event and this unfortunately is
another unique American event for all
different reasons but Sheriff you have a
different Theory you think the cartels
use human beings as ploy to distract
attention in order to take things like
fentanyl because they can make a lot
more money on the drugs explain
absolutely so what the cartels do is
they tie up border patrol Resources by
sending across large groups of give UPS
which is the 310 000 that was mentioned
this last Federal fiscal year but what
you're not looking at is a 28 000
getaways in in our County alone where
cartels tie up all the border patrol
Resources with large amounts of give up
so it opens up the border so they can
actually funnel in those that are
yeah
it's probably a Narcotics so it's
devious it is in there actually dropping
off certain groups out 30 miles away
from civilization and having them call
9-1-1 so that ties up our resources and
that's that's why we're seeing such a
large amount of fentanyl throughout the
whole the U.S it's devious and it's it's
also devilish right the human life is
nothing to them it's a commodity because
every person that you hear about all
these numbers are paying anywhere from
six thousand to fifteen thousand dollars
to cross our border you're talking 140
different countries 17 of which have
been on terrorist watch list or
countries of uh concern is you've got 11
kids and you've chosen to make this
place your home I love it changed quite
a bit
and our conversation yesterday you have
a landscaper from Mexico came here 10
years ago and he's as upset as you are
absolutely you have a housekeeper whose
18 year old son died of fentanyl
poisoning she discovered him after she
left my home and went home she's walking
in with her three and five-year-old and
to to imagine the horror that she had to
confront as she walked in and found her
son poisoned with fentanyl and then to
watch him deteriorate over two days and
that's just one of many stories in our
community and across our nation we've
seen 50 people in Yuma County die from
fentanyl overdose last year what do you
need
we'll need the border to be shut down we
need security this Administration to
actually secure our border Homeland
Security Public Safety and humanitarian
those are the three priorities that
sheriffs across the whole border have
been asking this Administration to do
from the very beginning and to see
mayorkas say that the border is secure
is a blatant lie thanks for having us
okay thanks Bill thanks for coming out
there today we're going to meet some
other folks from your community coming
up with the next thanks for coming and a
half I appreciate Jonathan line Sheriff
good luck to you okay thank you all
right I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade
and I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis